e
expected Market
return why would you invest or you could
be in which case you won't buy stocks it
can't be collectively negative nobody
would buy stocks
you once you got into negative might as
well leave the cash in your under your
bed
right okay folks you ready for the two
questions how many of you have picked a
company for your
valuation okay more hands than last time
we're moving in the right direction so
next Monday question is going to change
right how many of you have not picked a
company so hopefully the numbers will
shrick how many of you are not in a
group
yet so those 15 names that I see on the
orphan
list they're not orphans anymore you've
been adopted there a lot of names there
I it's still there so if you're no
longer an orphan remove your name from
that list right you're not not in that
list anymore so at least people know
that they need somebody for their group
so today we're going to continue our
discussion of risk free rates we're
going to complete it but we're also
going to start on this mysterious
concept which is the equity risk premium
which is what you would demand over and
above the risk free rate to invest in
stocks collectively so I'm going to
start today's class with a test about
the equity risk premium and lay the
foundations so how we think about
estimating it
best so the tough thing about Equity
risk premiums is you're trying to
estimate
you're trying to
estimate what people think they can make
on stocks over and above what you can
make on something risk-free right so
what's the most logical place if I asked
you what do you think you'll make on
stocks over and above T bonds what's the
most logical place to start Look
Backwards right we have 100 Years of
stock market data in the US and if you
take a 100 years stock market data you
can SL slice and dice it you can use a
historical past and if you're doing it
you're making an assumption right you're
assuming that the future will look like
the past but we do it in so many other
places why not this is the default way
in which people estimate Equity risk
Brams especially in the US they look
backwards a lot of history and they use
it as a prediction for the future so
let's say you decide to go down that
path here's my first question you want
to estimate the equity risk premium for
the future you can just look at the last
year what's the most recent data what
did the number look like last year what
did stocks do does does anybody
know 25% right roughly 25% so what was
the and and you know t- bonds earned
last year right minus 1.6% because the
price actually went down so the equity
risk premium last year was
26.6% you want to put that as in your
Equity risk it' be nice if we could make
that but there's no way you're going to
get that right so what's the problem
with one year could be a good year it
could be a bad year it could be a so
clearly not one how about the last five
years you think that'll be good enough
what's the question you're really asking
right the statistical question how noisy
is the
average in statistics classes how do we
measure when you comp put compute an
average of a bunch of data what do you
train to put in Brackets below it to
indicate to the world how uncertain you
are a standard error right a stand
standard deviation but a standard error
basically saying it could be plus or
minus you know what a fiveyear number is
going to look like the plus or minus is
going to wipe it out at five
years I've heard people say well if I'm
going to project out cash flows the next
10 years I should look at the last 10
this is nothing to do with what you're
projecting out for so that shouldn't
even enter the
equation there others there you a 10year
bond rate one no nothing to do that that
ultimately what you're trying to do is
even if you believe the past is a good
Pro estimate of the future you're trying
to come up with a number that you have
some degree of confidence in and I'll
give away where I am there is no
historical time period you could give me
where I feel comfortable enough with the
number you're going to give me that I
can value stocks for so I have to give
you an alternative but this is how 95%
of valuation the equity risk pram looks
comes from looking at
the so I i' I've made up a year let's
say that you're coming off a terrible
year for star we haven't had once since
so let's make it 2022 terrible year for
stocks down
20% you're Computing a historical risk
premium with that year added on so
basically you've been doing a track the
data in the US the most widely used data
set is from ibits and Associates go back
goes back to 1926 just gets updated with
the most recent year so let's say you
computed through 2021 and it was 52%
then 2022 happens and it's minus 20% you
add the minus 20% to history historical
data what is that going to do to your
Equity risk premium decrease it or
increase
it it's going to drop it right you think
so what so you're coming off a terrible
year for stocks and what are you telling
me I'm going to demand a lower risk
premium from this point on which makes
no sense at all right you come off a
terrible year you're feeling scared you
want a higher risk premium that's the
second problem with historical risk
beams is they cut in the wrong direction
after a crisis year like 2008 or 20 22
your historical risk premium gets
smaller and at the same time you're
feeling more risk in the picture so what
would you like you'd really like a
forward-looking number that reflects the
world you're in and I already said this
is going to be a rocky semester because
things are happening
right I don't want to go back and look
at the last 100 years I going to live in
the moment I want to get a
forward-looking number and I'm going to
give you a way of doing it but I'm going
to get you started on that right so I
want somebody to be
my guinea pig in this process so you're
going to be my guinea pig okay so what's
your name
again AER is going to be my guinea pig
I'm going to offer him an investment
where I can guarantee a dollar in cash
flows every year in
perpetuity and how much would you pay
for that investment
okay so so $1 is your cash flow it's
constant it's a perpetuity so I need a
discount rate what did I say it's
guaranteed in US dollars so right now
that rate is going to be a t bond rate
for but let's say it's 5% let's round it
up right one over 0.05 which is
$20 you see why $20 is a fair price
right you pay $20 5% of this so you'd
pay $20 I'm going to up the anti a
little bit Tyler I'm going to come to
you with a dollar every year forever but
it's not guaranteed anymore right don't
but I'm going to let you set the price
obviously would you would you pay $20
now that it's not guaranteed no less or
more way less let's not go to the way
less yet less right you see why right so
give me a number how much would you
pay 10 bucks okay if you pay 10 $10 has
Tyler given away what
is R premium is looking forward with the
$10 investment what are you making 10%
on this investment you have a 5% Equity
risk premium over the risk Cree you see
where I'm going right the way I'm going
to compute a forward-looking premium for
stocks is I'm not going to ask you what
risk premium would you like to make I'm
going to look at what you pay and when
you get scared what do you do you push
down what you pay you push up your risk
premium and will that number change
every time the price you pay changes the
risk we have a forward-looking dynamic
premium a lot of do eyes to Dot and teas
to cross but that's where we're going to
end up on the equity risk premium
discussion we're going to start with the
prevailing status quo look at the past
and I'm going to tell you everything
that makes me uncomfortable with using
that and I'll also make a confession
before 2008 I used to let people get
away using historical risk premiums post
20 8 I think you even lost the Fig
Leaf we say what happened in 2008 to
change that that that shift away but
today we're going to talk about risk FR
so before we do that though I want to
kind of finish off the risk free rate
discussions
inspection so let's go back to where I
left you in the packet if you remember I
I came up with three different ways of
estimating the default spread for Brazil
remember the three ways were
I could use a Brazilian dollar
Government Bond compared to the USD Bond
and take the difference it works only if
you have a dollar Bond so if Russia has
a Euro Bond I can compare to the German
Euro Bond and take the difference that
def fall spread that number was
3.17% the 10e Brazilian government bond
rate in RI was
12.3% I subtract out the the default
spread I come up it should be 9.13% so
fix that type of 99.13% I'm subtracting
out the spread from the 12.3% the second
approach I looked at the CDs spread
2.82% If I subtract that from the 12.3%
I get
9.48% the third approach is to use the
local rating which has a default spread
of 2.83% you subtract that out you get a
nine so I get three different risk free
rates right 9.17 to9 if I just picked
based on the risk r r and you wanted to
get a high value for your company INRI
which one are you going to go with the
lowest or the
highest yours lowest because you want a
low risk R rate I'm going to make a
statement that's going to sound absurd
but I'll back it up it doesn't matter
which of the three you pick as long as
you stay consistent see consistent what
Sense little later in the process we're
going to open up the box of equity risk
premiums for countries like Brazil and
there we will have to come up with the
default spread to come up with the
equity risk premium and there I'm going
to ask you what default spread did you
use to get the risk free rate and I'm
going to make you stick with that same
default so if you pick a high default
spread which gives you a lower risk free
rate that's now going to show up as a
higher risk premium it effectively will
keep you in check and give you so don't
sit here two hours trying to pick which
of these three just pick one and keep
moving at least remember which one you
pick and then come back to it later in
the process
so we looked at three tests let's move
on to fourth one let's say you've
decided that you want to do evaluation
in real
terms I'll tell you in the US I almost
never encounter valuation or a project
analysis done in real
terms partly because the world lives in
ninal
terms in fact on April 15th try filing
your tax return in real terms so I infl
i' have income but I'm going to take
inflation out of it
and I'll pay taxes on my real income it
doesn't work that
way the world operates in noral terms so
it's easier to stay in normal terms when
would you do things in real terms when
inflation gets to be 20 25 30% you
finally throw up your hands say this is
too volatile and too messy I'm going to
do things in real terms so you're more
likely to do this in Honduras or
Argentina or Venezuela then you are in
the
US and to do things in real terms you
need a real risk free rate and remember
I showed you a real risk free rate last
session the tips rate right you saying
but that's a US real risk free rate a
real risk free rate actually is a real
risk free rate there's no us attached to
it and in a world where there are no
barriers to Capital and trade and that's
a big
F A real risk free rate should be a real
risk free rate all over the globe and
here's why let's suppose I told you the
real risk free rate is 2.3% in the us
and 4% in Brazil and capital flowed
freely tell me what's going to
happen it's going toor us the capital
will move from the US until what happens
the 4% moves down to 2. I know that in
the real world there are barriers that
prevent but if you're doing evaluation
real terms I'm going to give you an
escape hatch but I want you to have the
explanation ready because somebody's
going to challenge you on it so you're
valuing a v velan company in real terms
you pull the US tips rate and make that
your real risk free rate you're going to
get push back right it's a Venezuelan
company using a real risk free rate in
the US and the only defense I can offer
is you know in a world where things
converge this is as good a start as
possible so it's not perfect but you can
see why the tips rate can be used as a
risk free rate pretty much anywhere in
the world that you're doing a real
valuation a real analysis a real project
assessment
now let's go back to a question I asked
you at the start of last session right
we talked about risk-free rates in
different currencies and we talked about
how to estimate so now we have a way of
estimating risk free rates so start of
2025 I estimated risk free rates in
about 40
currencies you know I had to stop at 40
I needed a government bond rate in the
local currency to get started and there
only about 40 currencies where there's a
local government bond rate in that
currency then I cleaned up like I did
for the Brazilian so the the great part
of this graph are the risk-free rates in
different currencies I think you kind of
answered this question last session but
since it's such a critical answer I want
it to be
affirmed why do risk free rates vary
across currencies I didn't ask why do
Government Bond rates right it's why do
risk free rates vary across
currencies what's the answer to that
question yeah
yes inflation that's it it's the only
thing you're saying but don't risky
countries have high no it's if it's
truly risk free I've taken out the risk
effect the only thing that causes in
Risk free rate so high inflation
currencies will have high risk-free
rates low inflation currencies will have
low risk free rates and deflationary
currencies will have negative risk free
rates it can
happen so when you look at difference in
inflation you'll essentially see risk
free rates varing can risk free rates
change over time of course why because
inflation changes over time this is from
2020 risk-free rates in the US Treasury
rates
collapsed there it is right between
that's the start of 2020 through not
even the start February 14th of 2020
through March 23rd across the board
rates
collapsed
why Co shut things down inflation kind
of dissipated right what what could you
go by consumption dropped off real
growth of course dropped through the
floor so not only do risc free rates
vary across currencies they vary across
time I have some bad news for you you
value a company today what's your risk
free rate you're doing it in dollars 4
and a half% when is your project
due May
5th you might have to at least change
the risk free rate closer to that day
you don't have to redo the whole
valuation but it could change your buy
to a sell so don't won't pull the
trigger on buy or sell till much later
in this process because who knows what
rates will be 10 weeks from now rates
can change across time different across
currencies but if inflation is the
reason why rates vary across currencies
and now have an opening on how to
estimate a risk-free rate in any
currency remember I showed you the graph
with 40 currencies which said government
bonds there are lots of currencies on
that not on that list
the Egyptian Pound The V and so you can
go down the list you saying what do I do
with those
currencies here's a quick and easy way
to get a risk free rate in any currency
in 2015 I was valuing an Egyptian bank
and I really really really wanted to
value in Egyptian PS because I never
valued a company in Egyptian
PS I went looking for a Government Bond
right none the Egyptian government
borrows money but it borrows from the
World Bank it borrows from Banks it
doesn't issue
bonds so here's what I did I started
with the USD Bond R you saying that is
so us Centric guilty is charged but I
trust the t-bond rate because it's a
traded rate there's demand and Supply
setting it and it was let's say 2% I'm
sorry it was uh it yeah it was roughly
2% so this was risk free rates were low
and then I estimated two numbers one was
the expected inflation rate in the US
which then was one and a half % and the
second was the expected inflation rate
in Egypt which is 15% let me pause right
there the Egyptian inflation rate is
roughly 13 a half% higher than the US
and if inflation is the reason risk-free
rates should be different the risk free
rate in Egyptian Pound should be roughly
13.5% higher than the USD bond rate so
if you're in a hurry you take the two
and you add 13 and a half you come up
with 15 A5 per. you're saying what's
this convoluted calculation you did
rates know rates are have a compounding
effect inflation is on top of real rates
if you want to do it more precisely you
take one plus the US dollar rree rate
you take one plus the inflation rate
effects and you come up with a more
refine you see why if you're in a hurry
I'm going to let you get away with 15 a
half% after all the refine you got
15.57% do the full calculation there the
effect will be large enough that you
will
notice at this point you have no excuse
on any currency to say you cannot come
up with a risk free rate in that
currency as an estimation question of
the numbers here what might be the
number that you have trouble with t bond
rate you should be able to get right
inflation rate in the US is Trivial it's
easy to get all you have to do is
compare two Market numbers what are the
two Market numbers that you can compare
to get an inflation rate
T bond rate and a tips rate make them
both 10 they're both so you can take
that difference which leaves you with
the number that you're going to have
trouble with how the hell am I going to
get an expected inflation rate for
Egypt try the IMF for the World Bank
site they have estimates of expect
inflation are they going to be wrong or
100% of the time but as long as you use
that same wrong inflation rate in both
your numerator and your denominator
you're going to be okay again this is
not the you want to spend days on it's
not worth it make an inflation judgment
come up with a risk-free rate and move
on so on January 1st
2022 the 10year t- bond rate in the US
was
1.51% two seme two two Springs I measure
my teaching life in Spring semesters
that was two spring semesters ago three
spring semesters ago
one and a half% historic lows right so
when you look at a rate like that
and you're you're an analyst you say
that rate looks too low it's human
nature so what do you want to do you
want to replace it with something that
you feel more comfortable with so in
that decade when t- Bond rates were
really low there were practitioners who
replaced it with what they called a
normalized rate we talked about this
being a subject so you could take for
normaliz you could take an average over
the last you know 30 years you know so
basically you could replace the current
rate with that or maybe you can use a
current risk free rate and keep moving
so the question is should you replace a
rate that looks too low or too high with
something that you think is more
normal what do you think what sounds
more realistic if you do the first few
years risk period that you have and then
adjust it four years five years down the
line to what something more consistent
last 10 years but should you be
measuring consistency with the last 10
years or consistency with the inflation
numbers you're using in your cash flows
you see where I'm going right so if you
tell me that inflation is coming back
after year five and rates will go up
then that inflation should also be
showing up in your cash flows which
means the net effect of changing your
risk free rate is going to be far more
neutral than you think
because whatever you do to your risk
free rate you should also be doing to
your cash flow so if inflation is a
driver my advice to just leave well
enough alone you have enough on your
plate already what the heck are you
doing trying to forecast interest rates
for the next
decade leave the t- bond rate at 2% but
then use a really low inflation rate
when you do your cash flows you won't
get that
assist and that's going to keep your
value so consistency here just means
whatever inflation you're building and
and that's part of the reason I would
not try to replace current rates and as
I said last
week you tell me how old you are and I
can tell you what normal looks like most
of you look at a 4.5% rate and what's
your reaction looks really high why
because you've lived in a world with 2%
rates I had a 71y old in my valuation
class alumni are allowed to take my MBA
value ation class he started in the
market in he got his MBA in
1978 he looked the 4 and a half% and say
what do you think you know he said it
looks
really
low because his frame of reference is
198s T Bond rates was 6 and a half seven
7 and a half% normal is not some magical
number it reflects you know that what we
Define as normal is set around 30 to 35
years when we so what you see then so
what you think of as normal
music is what you used to so you notice
that you know when you get to be 65 you
who listen to the crappy stuff what is
this you know it's just a reflection of
the fact that your normal got stuck on
30 and that's part of the problem here
is you're you're stuck in time and you
can't really let go so I know it's tough
to do an analyst break this rule all the
time try trying to for I in fact in my
spreadsheet I allow you to change I will
give you the RO to hang
yourself if you want to do
it but I want you to think long before
you pull that rope out and say do I
really want to do
this and that's the other question
remember the fact that rates were low
for the last decade who we blame the FED
did it everything the FED did it that's
an incredibly lazy answer why ratees low
the FED did it why ratees High the FED
did it why ratees vola the FED did it
removes all responsibility from your
shoulders is why rates change it's true
rates in the last decade were low but to
show you why they're low I'm going to
create what I call an intrinsic risk
free rate I've been doing this for a
long time in terms of computing this
number I'll tell you what I do what did
we say goes into risk rate expected
inflation and an expected real interest
rate right I took the inflation rate
every year I know it's reaching and but
I took the so let's say the inflation
rate is 3% I took the the real GDP
growth in that
year say it's
2% add 3 plus two you get five that's my
intrinsic risk rate that's that's
basically what you're getting in these
columns red number is the inflation the
green is the real GDP growth that's my
intrinsic risk re rate the black line is
my actual t- bond rate do you think the
two seem to move
together you can do the correlation if
you want you can see there are your but
clearly the trend lines match up the
correl I think was
88% look at the last decade 2011- 20
what do you
notice lowest inflation decade in a
century and in terms of real growth and
neic real growth what's low plus low
low why were rates low in the last
decade it wasn't the FED it was low
inflation plus low real growth did the
FED at the margin effect rates that's
that's causing that noise around the
number of course it
does fact in 2022 rat shot up and people
blame the FED what happened in
2022 mean you started paying for things
and noticing that things were going my
burrito which was at 9.99 for an entire
decade became
$14.99 she's burrito who cares but that
played out across the market right we
saw 8% inflation for the first time
since the 1970s
inflation was back and guess what the t-
bond rate did it went up what did the
FED do chase the market it raised rates
but it was chasing the market all the
way
through so when you look at rates I want
you to remember ultimately it's
inflation and and real growth that
drives those rates a Fed at the margin
can do only so if at some point in this
year rates go up and you say why isn't
the FED lowering
rates you can't do much if inflation is
back and real growth is
strong final point about risk free rates
talked about currencies with negative
risk free rates and it does freak people
out I understand why it freaks people
out it's changed I mean all these
currencies now are back to positive
numbers but the Swiss rank the Euro the
Japanese yen in 2019 all had negative
risk
rates it's kind
of unnatural
right it actually re created these very
strange things in Europe where Danish
homeowners who bought a house with a
mortgage the bank mailed them a
check every month because the mortgage
rate had become mildly negative it's not
something you even think about you say I
borrow money and you pay me this is
amazing but that's what negative rates
do is it kind of turns the whole word on
its
head but there's a problem with negative
rates right you can't go below a certain
number why are you required to put your
cash in a
bank so if I say the rate is minus 1%
you just hold as cash you keep the money
right you're saying why don't people
just keep the cash when you have
negative rates let's say you have 10
million
do let's say you decide to keep it all
at home first don't tell me where you
live because I might pass the message on
you first have to hire you know all
kinds of security and you know who knows
we you might have things eating through
paper and the currency gets
eaten the problem is we we've created a
world where cash we don't use cash
anymore we create the 50 years ago
interest rates might not have turned
negative because we were used to
carrying cash paying with cash I've been
behind people in a line whose Apple pay
stops working and it's almost like oh my
God my life is done what am I going to
how am I going to pay have you ever seen
this thing called currency might want to
put in your pocket just in case in a
cash free Society rates can turn
negative but they can't become minus 10%
there's a Tipping Point where people
will just hold the cash or just but
rates can turn
negative and if they do turn negative
the question is should you continue to
use them because remember you start with
the risk free rate and build up to it
you start with a negative number going
to come up with a low cost of equity and
low cost of capital so that was the
fundamental question I was asked from
European analyst is hey Euro risk free
rates look negative should I make it
positive you know how some of them made
them made it positive they took the
minus and they drew a line through it
say it looks plus it's a it's magical
you can't do that right others use the
normalized approach take the average
rate over the last 10 years but that
became a fundamental question so we'll
come back and talk about it because I'll
value hinin in September of
2019 the Euro risk free rate was
negative and I'll give away what I did I
left it negative but then when I did
cash flows and growth rates you saw that
same negative phenomenon kicking there I
actually found hinin to be overvalued
not undervalued even though rates were
negative which dispenses this whole
mythology of rates get really low or
they get Negative the value is going to
explode through the air just be
consistent you control both the discount
rate and the cash flows as long as
you're consistent by assumptions you can
use low rates High rates negative rates
and it's all going to even out yes those
banks have negative rates was that
government enforced or do the banks it's
Market set right it's demand and Supply
the T the Euro the German Euro Bond it's
demand and Supply there were Bond buyers
actually willing to buy these
bonds with negative rates banks in a
sense are you know triggered to that so
it's it's it's got nothing to do with
government regulation just you an
deflation environment negative growth
the bottom falls out
let's talk about
uncertainty now a lot of stuff on this
page but my point when you talk about
Equity risk premiums is everything
affects it let's go through the list
first doesn't depend on your risk
aversion as a person absolutely and what
what determines risk
aversion first yeah one is life
experience but some of it basically
you're born with
right I have four kids I can tell you
which one of my kids is going to be
invested in fixed income for the rest of
his life and which one's going to be the
option
Trader my oldest son he's 35 still walks
down the stairs holding on to the
banister I might fall now how about
right now fixed income guy if you ever
saw one my youngest when he was 2 years
old took off from the top step expecting
to be caught before he hit the bottom
option Trader to the core right so some
of this you're born with second do you
think age matters are older people more
RIS ofs or less risk
of why because you've learned what life
can dish out you're older you're more
responsi is so you know what the
implication is right as a market ages
what should happen to equity risk
premiums should actually get higher
because you know the Japanese
Market has a demographic problem
Equity risk are going to be higher there
the Chinese market is a demographic bomb
waiting to go off and if Equity risk
Reams go up what we what's going to
happen to stock
prices they'll have to go down because
you'll have to get a higher return to
compensate do you think I'm I'd be
treading on dangerous territory that
your sex matters men more risk ofers
than women or what do you think that
young women are more risk averse than
young men my four kids learned how to
drive the only one of my kids whose car
I would get into when they
drove was my daughter because I've seen
what 20-year-old men can do in a car and
it is
terrifying young men are actually the
most dangerous risk staking group you
can think of and this is what I want you
to do next time you go to Investment
Bank walk into the trading room and look
around and what are you going to
see 25y old men maybe 30 if they're old
in front of computers playing with tens
of millions of
dollars so after one of these trading
scandals I wrote a piece on my blog it's
still there suggesting how Banks can
take care of this
problem first is you can make your
Traders more diverse that takes a long
time I said here's what you need need to
do what's your only check on a
25-year-old male taking too many
risks a
mother a mother not a family they don't
listen to their siblings right they'll
actually take more risk father who cares
what he says so he said here's what you
need to do you hire a Trader hire his
mother
too make her sit in the chair behind
saying what are you doing now it'll slow
the process down so what you don't don't
don't do that it's good to have your
it's the greatest risk tool you can
think of you say but I have to pay the
mothers hey think $100,000 a year for
not having that $2 billion trading
Scandal it's well worth
it risk aversion varies across people
does it vary across
time yeah I mean remember Co you started
the 2020 feeling pretty good in my March
2020 I don't know whether I have a
future left
it can vary across people it can vary
across time second more economic
uncertainty will lead to higher Equity
risk
premiums little later in this class
maybe in the next class we're going to
talk about why Equity risk premiums vary
across
countries okay if you're in Venezuela
you feel an immense amount of course
your Equity risk Prem is going to be
hard but even in a market like the us as
you go through time could you feel I
mean mention of a tariff does increase
economic uncertain I'm not taking a
political stance here it just makes the
future a lot more uncertain your Equity
risk premiums will reflect third
inflation and interest rates I'll tell
you the problem is not inflation per se
that does cause rates to go up it's when
inflation goes up it also becomes more
unstable when inflation becomes unstable
it basically makes everything more risky
higher Equity risk bres do you think the
way information comes to equity markets
affect Equity risk
premiums where does the information
usually come from comes from companies
which are required by Disclosure to
reveal it and if there are holds and
disclosures in that's going to affect
your Equity risk PR countries where
disclosure laws are not as complete will
have higher risk premiums than countries
without what about liquidity yeah you're
in a market where you don't have much
money flowing into the market Egyptian
Market at one point in time you know how
they recorded trades there was a guy
with a CH board I'm not kidding in front
of the exchange and every time there was
a trade he wrote in chalk what the trade
was you want to try that in the New York
Stock
Exchange you couldn't keep up right but
there were so few trades they could
actually didn't even fill the board so
you're a market where there's a lot of
liquidity the equity risk premium should
be lower than in the market where
liquidity dries up but even in a market
like the US are there periods of
liquidity dries up I remember October
G could not Place its commercial paper
largest commercial paper issue in the
world was unable to place the commercial
paper because there weren't enough
people willing to buy it higher Equity
risk
premiums what about catastrophic
risk I won't I won't don't mean to scare
you but you wake up one day and you hear
about a nuclear bomb that's been La I'm
I'm sure you'll have other things on
your mind than Equity risk premiums but
worries about nuclear war will play out
as a higher Equity risk
premium so that's catastrophic risk can
government policy affect Equity risk
prams yeah so if you're if you have a
government whose policy is unstable it
keeps CH the equity risk premiums will
have to reflect and finally can central
banks affect Equity risk
premiums I think so and I'll tell you
why a good Central Bankers should be in
the old days when you children you know
what you what what they used to say
right they should be seen and not heard
a terribly cruel thing I'm sure in Hinds
side but Central Bankers should be seen
and not
heard because when they talk too much
and they talk about what they're going
to do they can add to the mix they can
add that's a long list right you're
saying everything affects Equity risk
frams Welcome to the Real World that's
exactly right everything that happens
around you small or large is affecting
Equity risk beams which means Equity
risk premiums can never be a constant
number this morning I was when I was
teaching my my corporate finance class
somebody works at um at a regulated
company came in and said is there a way
I can get a way of getting Equity risk
premiums where it doesn't change much
over time I want something nice and
stable I said you live in a world where
everything is
changing picking a number that's stable
might make you feel more comfortable but
it's not
real a good equity premium number should
be unstable should reflect the times
here so let's start with the
conventional way in which most people
still estimate Equity risk premium they
look backwards and when you look
backwards there are two things you're
assuming first is the things will revert
back to the way they used to be it's
called mean reversion it's a very and
and I'll admit it's a strong force in
businesses and
markets things revert back often so if
you have a basketball player who
historically has shot know 45% of his
three-pointers and he's shooting
20% you say well he's just having a bad
patch and odds are that if you watch him
over another 10 games but if it's Steph
Curry that might not work
why he's got a great lifetime average
he's shooting well below that lifetime
average this season why is assuming me
version not going to
work he's getting older
there's been a structural change in the
process you can sign Mike Scherzer but
he's not going to win or pitch with the
RAF because he's older you saying what's
this got to do with historical risk
breams when you look at the last 100
years of stock market in the US and you
get Equity risk premium not only
assuming Equity risk premiums mean
revert but you're also assuming that the
US Equity Market has not really changed
you see why the 2008 to me was the
wakeup date for this what did 2008 show
us first that the line between developed
and Emerging Markets was a hazy one
there was this Gray Line on any given
day who knows what any Market could look
like the second you didn't you shouldn't
have needed the reminder but a lot of us
got the reminder anyway that the US was
not the global economy anymore that we
were all connected at the
hip in other words it was saying the
structure has changed what the heck are
you doing looking at 1926 through 2008
averages but people continue to do it so
let's look at what the numbers look like
on my web page I update this at the
start of every year I never use it but I
update it
anyway so basically this is my version
of the historical risk premium you might
find in one of the know one of the
commercial sites out it's very close
because we draw on the same data it's
the same
market now
there's my historical risk premium for
the US let me rephrase it these are my
historical risk premiums for the US
plural is it how come you have many
depends on what slice of History I look
at I can go all the way back to 1920 28
which is my starting year I could go
back 50 years I could go back 10 years I
could go back 20 years each slice is
going to give me a different number it's
going to depend on what I use as my
risk-free investment t- bills are
shortterm T bonds are long-term might
get different numbers it even depends on
how I compute my
average sounds mysterious right there
are two ways you can compute average the
conventional is if I have 100 Years of
returns I add 100 numbers up and divide
by 100 that's a simple average the
second is what's called a compounded
average the nature of investing is
returns compound I'll give you a very
simple example to bring it home let's
assume you have a $100 today you invest
in something it doubles next year so
what's your percentage return next year
100% And the next year the year after it
hals what's the percentage return in
year two then if it Hales minus 50% you
know what the arithmetic average return
over the next two years
is no no it's plus 25% through the magic
of averaging I've convinced you that
even though you start with 100 and end
with 100 you made a 25%
return that's the problem with
arithmetic averages the truth is you
made nothing you're back to where you
started and geometric averages capture
that so let's look at the range of
numbers here it ranges from I think the
lowest value I got at the start of 2025
was
5.44% and the highest number I have is
13 and A5 per. you see why I coulded
research analyst like a table like this
remember we talked about
bias what is bias we want to come up
with a high number for a company you're
going to pick an equity which which
premium are going to pick if you want a
high number for your company the lowest
number or the highest number you're
going to go with the lowest you want a
low number for your company you pick the
highest it's like being in a buffet you
pick the equity risk premium want to get
the answer you wanted to see it's a
recipe for disaster and they forgotten
basic statistics remember those standard
errors when I tell you the historical
Equity risk pre for the us over t-bot
and I'm going to stick with t bonds
because my risk free rates a longterm
and I'm going to stick with geometric
averages because discounting compounds
5.4 if you if you force me to pick a
number on this table I'd pick
5.44% then I'm going to put a caveat the
standard error in that number is about
2.12% somebody want to help me out there
on what that clear why don't you tell me
what if I have a
5.44% equity risk premium and I so let's
round it up 5.5% Equity risk 2% standard
error tell me I I know nothing about
statistics you have the data tell me
what that tells you about the equity
risk cream going
forward with one standard deviation and
when you do that well how much
confidence do you have in your number 67
which means you can be wrong one/ third
of the time that's a lot of time I could
you be give me something more precise
95% confidence
two standard errors and with two
standard errors what are you telling me
it could be anywhere from one and a half
to 10% fat lot of good that does mean a
valuation right and that's exactly what
people are building valuations on a
number that's got such a wide range it
could be 2% it could be
10% it's backward
looking and it's definitely
noisy there's a reason I haven't valued
a company with a historic rpr probably
in 25 years
it's this re I don't trust it I don't
know what it tells me about the future
so the estimates are noisy and you you
know I like the word noisy but it's
basically reflecting the statistical
standard
error see look at an even longer time
period in the US you can go back to 1871
there's data going back to 1871 but
there you run into a little bit of a
problem you have more data but you know
what the US Equity US economy and the US
Equity market look like in 187 anyone
come out of the Civil Wars it was an
Emerging Market the market itself has
changed so trying to get more data is
not going to solve this
problem there is no escape hatch if you
just keep digging and digging and
digging trying to get more data and
second there's another problem when
people use this us Equity risk PR they
use it outside the US as their Equity
risk
Prem the most successful Equity Market
of the 20th century was the US and what
have we done we've
estimated the equity risk Prem you would
have earned in that market but let's say
it was 1919 you were a wealthy person
and you wanted to invest your money you
had no idea what was coming the rest of
the century I would think you know the
biggest Equity Market maybe Austria is
said I'm going to send my money to
Austria 25% of your money what happened
to the Austrian Equity Market you think
after the second world war got wiped out
my like by Russian investment in luk
oil one of the problems with using
historical prems in the US is you're
probably overstating your Equity risk
because you've let survive it's called
survivorship bi you pick the most
successful Market you reverse
engineering and you're trying to apply
it for the next 100
years so file that away historical RS
are under reliable but I'm going to take
a
little tangent here and come back to
talking about better ways of estimating
Equity risk groups if it's difficult to
get a historical risk premium for the US
it's a nightmare to get it for countries
outside even European markets did not
trade they actually have this break in
the historical data 1940-45 the US
contined to trade but many of the
markets sto trading so you you have to
start if you take a market like India
this the stocks have been around a long
time but you go back to 1960s 1970s you
had probably 20 companies that accounted
for all the trading very IL liquid
Market if you're lucky you might have 20
years 25 years of data and if you if you
went back to the previous page and
looked at the Standard air as my time
period goes from 100 years to 50 years
to 10 years my Standard air gets larger
no surprise purely
statistic I remember a Vietnamese
analyst emailed me and he said look I'm
having trouble getting you know I'm
valuing the company he said can you look
over the valuation and I said I will
because i' never seen a Vietnamese
company actually Val I was curious I
look through and he has a risk premium
for Vietnam an equity risk premium said
where' you get it he said I Ed a
historical Equity risk premium for
Vietnam how long have Equity markets
been in
Vietnam if you're lucky maybe 15 years
12 years yeah 10 years of data he said
the risk premium is 6.83% he had the
second decimal point nailed down and I
said you might want to estimate the
standard error in that number before you
use this because the standard error is
actually
8% which means you basically know
nothing about the equity risk PR by
looking at the past so you can't go back
because you don't have historical
premiums so if I were a brazili if I
wanted you to Value Brazilian company
you have two
choices one is you can say come back in
100 years I'll have enough historical
data to estimate your risk premium but
my guess is you're not coming back and
I'm not going to be around the others to
do something today so I'm going to give
you a pathway to estimating Equity risk
beams for markets that don't have a lot
of history and I'm going to use a number
that we've already used in the context
of risk free rates so let me do a logic
exercise let's suppose you have an
equity risk premium for the US right see
you feel whatever you know and we talked
about historical PR noise you but at
least you have 100 Years of data and
you're trying to estimate a risk premium
for a country an Emerging Market a
Vietnam or Brazil if the Equity risk
Prem for the US is 5.44% would you
expect the equity risk premium in Brazil
and Vietnam to be higher or
lower higher right so you can only
figure out a way of how much higher make
our lives a lot simpler so I'll give you
the first way you can come up with the
equity risk premium for a Brazil or
Vietnam you start with the US Equity
risk premium and remember that default
spread that I used to clean up I'll
bring it back into play and say I'm
going to add it to my us Equity risk
premium to come up with an equity risk
premium for Brazil so in um in in 2025
let's say my us Equity risk is 4.33%
I'll talk about where I got the 4.33%
later remember the default spread I came
up with for Brazil 2.83% based on the
rating you add the 2.83 3% to the
4.33% you come up with an equity risk
premium for Brazil of
7.16% so basically I start with the
rating I come up with the default spread
you can use a sovereign spread if you
don't like ratings add it to the US
premium this is if you can call it that
the state-ofthe-art of estimating Equity
risk premiums at investment Banks they
take they have a base premium for the US
God only knows where it comes from they
added the
spread now do you see why took that
spread out of your government bond rate
because if I did not do that you'd be
double counting the same spread right
once through what you call the risk free
rate and once through this risk
bre
yeah that's
well when it's used as a default spread
you basically saying That's Country risk
but I think you're on to something that
default spread of 2.83% is for doing
what buying a Brazilian Government Bond
right but that's not what you think of
doing you think of buying Brazilian
equities now again I'm going to ask you
in two question and I'll come back to
you are Brazilian are equities riskier
than Bonds in a country or safer riskier
why because you're always the last guy
in
line so you'd expect that additional
risk premium for Brazil to be greater
than
2.83% to the extent that equities are
riskier than debt 30 years ago that's
exactly where I started because this is
what investment bankers showed me and I
say I see where you're starting but why
are you stopping there the 2.83% is the
default spread here's what I'm going to
do to converted into an equity risk
Brave I want to measure how risky
equities are in Brazil and how risky
bonds are in Brazil and I'm going to use
a very simplistic measure of risk for
equities I took the baspa which is the
Brazilian Equity index I computed the
standard deviation from the Brazilian in
the in the equity index to be 30% then I
took that Brazilian Government Bond on
which my default spread was 2.83% I
computed the standard deviation that
number to be 18% Let's do an algebra
prom
if you're buying a government bond with
an 18% standard deviation you're
demanding a 2.83% spread you're buying
Equity with a 30% standard deviation
your spread should be roughly scaled up
to capture that additional volatility
the 2.83% then becomes no so you can I'm
sorry I'll go to it becomes
4.25% and you essentially have an equity
I'll come back to the previous page so
basically it come becomes a larger
number so I've taken the default spread
approach and have adjusted the default
spread for the higher risk of equity
he's saying what was that middle page
Goldman Sachs about 30 years ago came up
with a different way of trying to scale
for risk they said government they
didn't use the Government Bond at all
they started with the US Equity risk
premium and they looked up two standard
deviation just like I did but the
standard deviation they looked up well
one was the standard deviation for the
baspa 30% and the other was the standard
deviation in the S&P
500 you see what the algebra looks like
that right the S&P 5 is 18% standard
deviation My Equity risk premium is
4.33% if Brazil's Equity index has a 30%
standard deviation its risk premium
should be much higher based on that
percentage you get an equity risk
premium of
7.22% already again just like the risk
free rate you can see numbers changing
depending on which approach I used I
almost never use the default spread
approach because to me it's like a
bludgeon really the choice is between
this approach we use just equities Bond
doesn't even enter the picture or the
third approach and I'll tell you one of
the reasons I have trouble with this
approach when I use I use it every year
to actually I use the Goldman approach
to see what the numbers would look like
it looks like Pakistan should have a
lower Equity risk premium than the
US you know why because the standard
deviation in the Pakistani Equity Market
is actually lower than the standard
deviation in the US why might that be
sopia
because there's no liquidity remember
for prices to change people have to
trade if you're in a market where
there's no liquidity the standard
deviation will be close to
zero if I use this approach any Market
where nobody trades that's a safe Market
it's the exact opposite but the problem
with standard deviation Equity it's a
joint effect of the risk of the country
and how liquid it is so I've tried this
and I get some really strange looking
numbers Costa Rica should have a very
low risk premium because nobody I guess
trades in cost I guess they're all in
the beach or in the rainforest I don't
know what they're doing but they're
definitely not
trading so when you look across these
approaches and you think about what to
do you're good jumping around know you
can see that the different the approach
you will see built into your
spreadsheets is this one where I take
the default spread because that's my
base approach but if you push back and
say I don't like the way you're scaling
up I'll let you use the bond default
spread the different numbers are not
different enough for me to take a stand
but essentially I'm adjusting your
Equity risk premium for what I think is
your country
risk so at the start of every
year I estimate Equity risk premiums by
country I start with an equity risk PR
for the US and I haven't done this yet
but I have but I have a forward looking
premium at the start of 2025 that
premium was 4.33% let me pause right
there so that's my equity for the us and
this may sound us Centric but I'm going
to stick with it I'm going to assume
that that's the equity risk Fram for any
mature Equity market so ask me the
question how do you know whether Equity
Market is mature right a
cheat I go to the ratings agencies and
if they give you a AAA rating I say
you're a mature Equity Market I know I'm
Outsourcing this but do you really want
to go around asking countries are you
mature are you not I mean I'd get into a
whole lot of trouble calling you
immature this way I can blame Moody so
you know what mark Market have AAA
ratings name some countries which have
AAA
ratings let's start close Canada I know
we're right now preparing for war and
I'm going to show what the war will look
like Canada AAA
rating in Europe it's
Germany Netherlands it's all northern
Europe southern Europe don't even look
it's ter terrifying when you go below
that line in Asia there is only one
country with a AAA rating
Singapore
Singapore the only AAA R Australia New
Zealand AAA rating all of those
countries are going to get
4.33% if you're not triaa rated then the
game is on right I take your rating I
come up with the default spread
initially I used to try to find a
Government Bond in that country and and
I finally gave up because only like 15
or governments which have government
bonds so so I started using a scalar by
looking at an index of emerging market
equities that S&P has and an index of
Emerging Market government bonds which
has an ETF I think that I think JP
Morgan maintains and I take the ratio at
the start of 2025 that number was 1.35
you saying how do I use that let's say
your default spread is 2% based on your
rating 2% * 1.35 is
2.7% you add that to 4.33% I've got an
equity risk P for your country
sounds abstract so let's look at the
numbers this is what the world look like
to me at the start of
2025 pick your part of the world
wherever you're from you can pick that
part of the world if you from North
America look elsewhere because there's
not much going on in North America you
got Mexico you got us even Mexico I
pushed out of North America you know how
much crap I get with this from people
saying you put me in the wrong geography
or the your borders the worst is when
people say you drew the borders wrong
know I get a disproportional large
number of Indians saying you got the
Kashmir border wrong look I'm not the UN
I'm trying not trying to Arbiter what
the borders are so draw whatever borders
you want this is the most downloaded
data set on my web page by far it gets
used in the strangest
places I remember getting an email from
the New Zealand milk board I didn't even
know know there was a New Zealand milk
bort I got this email they said we're
using your Equity risk
premiums to set milk prices for New
Zealand
farmers who are they selling the milk to
Zimbabwe hey but that at least they said
where are you getting your Equity risk
premiums and I sent them I said this is
not rocket science this is what I do I
start with the US premium and look up
the rating so basically the class played
out in a 15minute YouTube
video but sometimes you get emails and
not sure how to respond to
them right I'll give you one of my
favorite examples I know some I get an
email from a business person in Lebanon
about 12 years ago and here's how the
email begins you've destroyed Lebanon I
said what after 20 years of Civil War in
hisbah I am the guy who did this you
know what did I do and it turned out
that he was a Lebanese business person
was trying to sell his business and in
apprais r value the business use my
Equity risk premiums and you take a look
at Lebanon not exactly the safest part
of the world right you put in a risk it
was actually not as bad into but it was
like 20% Equity risk pre what happens if
you put a 20% Equity risk premium
discount rate it gets really high your
discount rate gets really high your
value gets really low this guy felt he'd
been chipped it was all my
fault initially I was going to say take
it up with your appraiser but I decided
discretion was a better part part of Val
here I said it's not my fault see whose
fault it is what drives that extra risk
premium your rating your rating is the
toilet you're going down with it I said
it's not my fault it's Moody's fault if
you want to take it on somebody I'll
send you their address it's 70 Church
Street New York New York
he there's no rock this is there's no
intellectual Firepower band this right
but it's completely transparent I'm not
saying I like this country I'll give it
a lower risk premium it's entire
he's saying what is this box at the top
this take a look at the countries in
that box you got Syria you got North
Korea you got
Sudan these are called Frontier markets
Russia is up there now it didn't used to
be Russia's made it in there you know
what these countries share in common
what did I need to get a country risk
premium I needed a rating these are
countries where there is no rating
Russian the Russian Sovereign ra ings
was suspended in 2022 they haven't come
back it it makes my life a lot more
difficult because we're not talking
about a small country somewhere right
we're talking about a you
know and for a long time if you didn't
have a rating they didn't show up on my
in my data set
until I get another email I get a lot of
emails from a Syrian business person
must be the last business person left in
Syria and he says look I'm a Syrian
business person I'm trying to come up
with a cost of capital for my company
I'm looking for an equity risk premium
for
Syria I was on your website looking for
it I couldn't find it why it's a very
aggressive why and I said you know what
you don't have a rating I can't come up
with an equity risk premium and then he
comes back know five minutes later he
says so what am I supposed to
do and I said you have a point you have
to run a business though I'm wondering
why coming up with a cost to cap for
your business is high up on your
priority list if you're in Syria and
I'll be looking for a lot of other
things but you clearly have some degree
maybe you have a competitive advantage
in your last name is Assad I didn't
check and I said you know what I'm going
to try to give you an equity risk brain
so here's what I do for countries that
don't have a rating there's a service in
Europe called political Risk Service
that attaches country risk scores to
countries that's all they do is they
measure they look at political risk
economic risk so the way the risk score
works there and among others The
Economist does that the World Bank does
it I've used PRS for a while so I'm
going to stick with them a lower score
is a riskier country a higher score is a
safer
country so last in 2025 when you look at
those PRS scores the high the safest
country in the world I think was
Switzerland or Sweden or what you know
it's
said and then of course you get down and
you get the mix and they do the frontier
countries so they do Russia they do
North Korea so let's take take as an
example um
Myanmar doesn't have a rating but has a
country risk score of
56 remember I'm not a purist I'm a
pragmatist guess how I came up with an
equity risk cream for Myanmar I look for
other countries which have scores
between 55 and 60 that have ratings and
an equity risk premium I found four then
what do you think I did I average the
four he think that is so simplistic
guiltiest
charge if you can come up with a
creative way of estimating an equity
risk PR for North Korea I would love to
hear it I haven't figured it out
yet but my table my table is full you no
matter where you operate in the world I
have a number for
you
okay it's an input that I need you're
saying how many companies are you going
to value that are in Myanmar I don't
have to have a company in Myanmar to
worry about Myanmar Equity risk frams
right if you're a lumber company and
you're getting your mahogany from
Myanmar hey guess what you're exposed to
Country risk
there so as you look at these companies
your countries you're going to see
difference in Risk so now let's seal the
deal we've got a way of getting an
equity we I still haven't finished that
that implied pre for the US I'll come
back to it but let's talk about these
Equity risk PRS and how they play out in
your company's valuation
the first approach is the default
approach you see at many investment
Banks is you tell me where you're
Incorporated I will use the equity risk
premium of the country in which you're
Incorporated I can't even imagine how
you defend this approach but it is the
default approach so what happens if
you're an Indian company you get the
Indian Equity risk you're a Russian
company you get the Russian Equity risk
premium if you're a South African
company you get the South African Equity
risk you're saying what's wrong with
that
could you be a South African company
know could be a diamond company the
beers where do you get your revenues you
don't get them in South Africa you get
them in Europe you get in North America
your operations could be all over and
I'm giving you the equity risk for of
the country in which you're
Incorporated so I'm going to give you a
second approach the second approach what
you do is you start with the risk free
rate you come up with the beta but you
bring in that country risk premium of
the countries in which you operate into
the process so basically if you're a
high beta company you're more more
exposed to Country RIS in a low beta
company which I think is not an
unreasonable but you're asking beta to
carry one more weight to all of the
other weights it's caring bet is
supposed to measure exposure to interest
rate risk and macroeconomic I'm saying
measure country risk as well and the
third approach I'm actually going to try
to isolate country risk and try to
identify whether you're particularly
exposed now talk about some of the
things you might look at that might make
your company particularly exposed to
Country risk so let's start with the
country of
incorporation versus where you operate
this is the status quo approach where
everything is based on where you're
Incorporated so if you're Incorporated
in a risky country you're going to end
up with a high cost of equity no matter
where you do
business you see what what kind of
effects this is going to have if you're
a South African company about 20 years
ago a lot of South African companies
start it's a gold mining company
actually that I was talking to moved
their incorporation from South Africa to
London can you do that yeah move your
country
over and I asked the CFO what why do you
do this and he said we make us less
risky I said what exactly do you do take
your mines that are in South Africa move
them to Yorkshire Lancashire or moving
your headquarters from you know
Johannesburg to London doesn't make the
risk go away but that's a kind of trap
you fall into and you think about where
you incorporate that drives all of the
risk so I'm going to stay with countries
of operation and within the countries of
operation I now have to come up with the
way of estimating the equity risk
premium for your company so if you have
a company it's operating all over the
world what's a one metric you can
generally find in that company's
financials that's broken down by
geography
revenu is often the only one so Beggars
can't be
choosers use Revenue weights could that
get you into trouble absolutely right
there are times you worry about where
are my factories where are I so the
first is to take a revenue weighted
approach of where you operate bring that
into your Equity risk
pre the second is you might say I don't
care about revenues it's where I operate
that I worry about risk I'll tell you
the kinds of companies where I don't
look at revenues I look at where you
operate and that becomes but in each of
the these case what are you doing you're
taking the countries where you either
sell or make and use them to come up
with a weighted
average so you can be a company in a
safe country that's incredibly risky you
can be a company in a risky country that
is incredibly safe infosis is an Indian
company but it gets 93% of its revenues
in the US and Western
Europe conversely Coca-Cola is a US
company that get 60% of its revenues
from some of the riskiest parts of the
world so what we're trying to do is
break out of the box of where you
Incorporated using the risk thinking
about what are the country and now you
see why I need the entire world to Value
even if my job is just valuing us
companies where does Microsoft get much
of its software
written probably in India even if they
sold nothing in India how can I just
ignore that risk when I value Microsoft
welcome to
globalization this is the dark side
right because effectively 30 years ago
you could said I'm going to be working
in the US I don't care about the rest of
the world that's not going to be the
case anymore because your companies are
exposed so I'll give you a couple
examples of Revenue weighted Equity risk
frames
embri you familiar with what embri does
you can tell what what does embri
do jets and also corate
if you take a short Hall flight in the
US one of those small Jets most of the
time you''ll be flying an embri jet it's
a very good aircraft
maker it's a Brazilian company it's
Incorporated there but it gets it at
least the time that it is they got 97%
of their revenues outside
Brazil mostly in North America selling
to Airlines North America and Western
Europe so in a revenue based approach
the equity risk premium I'm going to get
it's going to look very much like the US
pre I know there's a flaw here because
embra still makes it jets in Brazil I'm
ignoring the production but they don't
even tell you where their factories are
I'm going with
revenues take a look at mbeb what does
mbeb do sells beer it's part of Mev now
hu it's a huge the largest Brewer in the
world but Mev is the Brazilian version
of the Brewer and in this is in
2011 their revenues came from all over
Latin America they're a Brazilian
company but their risk comes from where
they sell not from where they
operate most cases I use Revenue weights
so when you value a company if it's a
consumer product company if it's a you
know just use Revenue ways I know that
it there there but the rest of the
information you don't have I'll tell you
one exception if you're Ving an oil
company don't use Revenue weights why
because what do you sell into a global
oil
market so if you're an oil company what
keeps you awake at
night where your oil comes from your oil
comes from Nigeria guess what you know
you got to worry about Nigerian country
risk
so if you have a company where that's
the case you might bring in where the
oil comes from make those your weights
so last example I I talked about
Coca-Cola and how it gets revenues all
over the world there's the equity risint
for
Coca-Cola you're saying why is it broken
down by region not by country
practically you know why Coca-Cola
doesn't break things down by country
that table would run 72 lines right many
companies will break things down by
region if you go back to that picture I
showed
you notice there a regional Equity risk
premium you know what that Regional
premium is computed as a weighted
average of the equity risk the country
is invaded by GDP so I'm doing the Asia
Equity risk premum China and India IND
will be weighted a lot more than Vietnam
in that premium the reason I compute
them is there are companies like
Coca-Cola which don't break their
revenues down by country they break it
down by
region and as you can see it's you know
it's sometimes
rad when you look at this data for your
company be ready for some frustration
Lisa you had a
question it'll still break it down
they'll do revenues by region so if
you're Accenture for instance which
provides Services they have a
geographical breakdown at their clients
and where they get their
revenues so it's not service versus
product it's more a question of you know
do they do the
breakdown that makes you risk less right
so in a sense it that's more for
production than for revenues it's not
easily transferable revenues but maybe
that's why the reason I don't care as
much about where I infosis his factories
because if India Goes to Hell in a hand
basket put 3,000 software engineers in
your fly them to some island in the
middle of the Indian Ocean you got your
production still back online right so
that's a good question to think about
and we'll talk about in the context of
Lambda one final point when you look
these so this is why I want you to pick
a company because if you look at the
footnotes for your company they will
have this geographical breakdown and
some companies it's incredibly
frustrating in terms of how they break
it down us companies are among the worst
you know the typical breakdown of
revenues for us company we get 72% of
our revenues from the US and 28% from
the rest of the world come on guys the
rest of the world is a really big
place is it Europe or is it Venezuela it
makes a big
difference or european companies have
their own vision of hell when it comes
to this right European companies will
tell you we get our you know 35% of our
revenues from the UK 45% from from
EMA you know what EMA stands for Europe
Middle East and Africa you bundle those
three this is I have no idea what you're
talking about here I remember and I'll
leave you with this you know so as you
look at your companies and you look at
the breakdown be prepared for the data
not being complete work with what you
have if you picked a company try doing
this for your company you saw that PA's
got the updated Equity risk frame see if
you can get a weighted average
ni
love
hey how are you